fill on the table with whole numbers to
write 0.25 in different ways so one way
to look at it is just this 2 and 0.25 is
in the tenths place so it literally
represents two tenths while the 5 is in
the hundredths place so it literally
represents five hundredths so that's one
way to represent it but then we can
start to rearrange value amongst these
two place values for example what
happens if we only have one tenth then
how many hundredths would we have to
have well one tenth is ten hundredths so
if we take the ten hundredths that we
took away from here and give it to the
hundreds place you're going to have 15
hundredths and you could verify that one
tenth plus 15 hundredths is equal to 25
hundredths or another way you could say
it is 10 hundredths plus 15 hundredths
is equal to 25 hundreds now another way
you could do it you could have no tents
and view it as all hundredths as all
hundreds because two tenths is the same
thing as 20 hundredths so 20 hundredths
plus five hundredths is 25 hundredths
let's do a few more of these these are a
lot of fun fill in the table with whole
numbers to write 20.1 in different ways
so here the table the two columns are
tens and tens so I guess the assumption
is is we're not going to give anything
to the ones place here and in the
original example we didn't have anything
in the ones place either so we could
write the the two in the tens place is
literally two tens and the one in the
tens place is it literally 1/10 but
let's think about what happens is we
regroup value from the tens place to the
tenths place so if we only have 1/10
then we have another 10 to play with
that we have to express in terms of
tenths so 10 is well it's clearly that
1/10 is the same thing as ten ones which
is the same thing as 100 tenths so we're
essentially giving a hundred tenths
notice we have we have an extra 10 to
play with ten value that is the same
thing as a hundred hundred over ten or
hundred tenths and we already had one
tenths
so 100 tenths plus 1/10 is going to be
101 tenths and it was really confusing
we have tens and tenths so now let's go
again what happens if we take all the
value in the tens place so now we have
two tens or 20 to play with well 20 is
how many tenths well you have ten tenths
per one so 20 is two hundred tenths and
so you take the two hundred tents that
you took out of the tens place add to
the 1/10 and you have two hundred and
one tenths let's do one more example
so let's write two point one and three
different ways so here it's between the
one and the tenths place so we could
write it as two ones and 1/10 we could
also write it as one one and now we've
seen this game before we have one extra
one to play with so that's going to be
ten tenths plus the 1/10 that was
already there gives us 11 tenths or if
we have no ones well two point one is
the same thing as 21 tenths the two
represents literally 20 tenths and then
you have the 1/10 so 20 tenths plus 1/10
is 21 10